jean pierre colombier ce dont je vous
remercie d'être en direct avec nous sur
rtl france 12 suicides dans la police
depuis le début de l'année on le disait
voilà les policiers qui alerte sur leur
situation depuis déjà plusieurs mois
plusieurs années même elle gérald
darmanin va donc recevoir les syndicats
de police cet après midi qu'est ce que
vous attendez de cette rencontre
rebonjour de cette rencontre précisément
en entendant strictement rien comme vous
l'avez dit fort bien souligner c'est pas
depuis plusieurs mois que le phénomène
des suicides est prégnant dans
l'institution policière ça fait des
années le taux de suicide dans la police
nationale et le plus important de toutes
les catégories socioprofessionnelles
donc l'interrogation elle était déjà là
et c'est d'ailleurs ce que nous avons
dénoncé très fortement et très
régulièrement
lorsque l'initiative du bureau de la
sécurité a été lancée car nous avons
souligné tout simplement que tout tout
les diagnostics qui pouvait être fait
sur le malaise que les cinématiques
policière était déjà sur les bureaux du
ministre donc c'est pour nous c'était
quelque chose qui n'avait strictement
aucun sens si ce n'est que de gagner du
temps que de permettre à un pouvoir
politique de gagner du temps à l'issue
du dans la perspective des élections
présidentielles et pour éviter que des
syndicats de police ne soit un peu trop
remuants donc la réunion d'aujourd'hui
je vois pas trop à quoi il va servir si
ce n'est à organiser une séance de
calinothérapie
le diagnostic du mal être de des
problématiques que rencontrent les
policiers au quotidien il est
parfaitement identifié
continue à jouer au fond conciliabules
n'a strictement aucun intérêt pour de
notre point de vue est ce que c'est un
phénomène qui traduit la difficulté du
métier mais aussi une prise en charge
psychologique insuffisantes selon vous
un peu tout ça je la société va mal que
je vais pas vous l'apprendre je dirais
les bulletins d'information qui se
succèdent sur votre chaîne comme sur les
autres d'ailleurs démontre qu'il y à
véritable problème
psychologique de dans l'ensemble de la
société donc a fortiori
c'est un pas que ça impacte une
institution qui et qui n'est pas bien
dans ses baskets qui est en crise depuis
depuis très longtemps qu'il a perdu
beaucoup de ses repères qui subit sans
cesse ddd à mille feuilles de
réglementation et de changement de
politique sécuritaire aussi inutile even
les unes que les autres cette
institution a besoin qu'on redonne du
sens à son métier vous savez il ya de
vieux débats y de départ qu'au fond qui
sont en train de se tenir qui vont bien
au-delà de ce qu'on a pu éventuellement
débattre au cours du mouvement de la
sécurité auxquels d'ailleurs n'était pas
convié les associations la petite
parenthèse et ses essais débats vont
dans le sens d'une remise en cause
totale de la place de la police au sein
de la société et ça on est passé à côté
on passe complètement à côté je vous
invite pas vous non plus vous les médias
réfléchir là dessus parce qu'on vous
communique pas le sens de ces
discussions qui vont très très loin et
qui vont dans le sens d'un
appauvrissement généralisé pas
simplement de la police mais plus
généralement du service public donc la
police n'est pas exempte de 2 de cet
impact ils le subissent et un sou
personnel permanent les policiers sont
obligés de travailler dans des
conditions épouvantables en
sous-effectif permanent à l'identique de
ce qui se passe dans les hôpitaux vous
savez on peut faire un parallèle mais
évident entre la crise que connaît le
système hospitalière et la crise que
peut connaître que connaît aujourd'hui
l'institution police en début de semaine
syndicat de police alliance a organisé
un grand oral pour écouter les
propositions des candidats de droite
candidat à la présidentielle est ce que
les promesses voilà concernant les
forces de l'ordre vous on
rassurés
les provinces voulait dire des promesses
des politiques des engagements des
politiques vis-à-vis des policiers c'est
ça la question oui qu'est ce que vous
avez pensé en général de leur discours
écoutez ils sont tous tous dans une
dynamique électorale les promesses
n'engagent que ceux qui ont bien envie
de les écouter alors venant d'alliance
d'ailleurs c'est assez particulier parce
que alliance et au je dirai au travers
de ses secrétaires généraux n'a jamais
caché ses accointances avec le parti des
républicains et anciennement ump donc il
ya derrière tout ça il arrière pensée
politique une arrière pensée de
positionnement politique alors soit par
rapport aux adhérents sur par rapport
aux au candidat moi ce que je regrette
c'est que à quoi ça sert à quoi sert
tout ce barnum de 2,2 de conciliation en
fin de discussion c'est pas si bidon
quoi je vois bien on voit bien qu'on est
dans une forme de deux shows de show
médiatique permanent on sort on sort
d'un nouveau de la sécurité de sécurité
qui a duré quatre mois quatre mois vous
rendez compte quatre mois de discussions
pour faire un diagnostic qui était déjà
déjà fait déjà bien bien délimitées
enfin de qui on se moque quoi alors là
nous avons tous les candidats de droite
un rationnement qui sont venus par
l'ancien candidat de gauche bon bah on
peut se poser effectivement la question
de ce à quoi ça peut ce sur quoi ça peut
déboucher je dis pas que monsieur
mélenchon meilleur interlocuteur en la
matière je pense qu'à un moment donné
vous savez il faut discuter que tout le
monde y compris je pense qu envie de
dire surtout avec ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord avec vous au tournoi ça ne sert
à rien là on a vu des gens qui ce
faisant on se fait plaisir qu'ils sont
venus dire opposition vous aime beaucoup
vous aime bien on sera prêt on sera avec
vous j'ai presque envie de dire
heureusement qu'ils soient pas contre la
police sera peuvent alors quand même
fatou sall et du barnum merci beaucoup
en tout cas jean pierre quelle ambiance
d'avoir réagi sur notre antenne je
rappelle que vous êtes porte-parole de
l'union des policiers nationaux
indépendants